this is your reminder that the BBC has
yet to address the consistent
transphobic leanings in its news
coverage and while the team behind
Doctor Who is not connected to this in
any way since this is a BBC owned
property I'm going to keep pointing it
out until the problem gets resolved
links in a pin comment below if you
don't know what I'm talking about I'll
stop saying it when it stops being a
problem
um
it
well that was
[Music]
[Applause]
new the giggle final special of David
tenant's limited run as the 14th
doctor and I know I know the thing that
has sucked all the oxygen out of the
room for every discussion of this
episode I know what it is I've already
had people poking me going hey what do
you think about this I will get to it
let me however talk about the rest of
the episode up to that thing which this
will also be your spoiler warning while
I am not mentioning what the thing is
and I will get to it a little bit later
I'm just going to be talking about this
thing as I go and doing my normal thing
of not necessarily going in
chronological order all the way through
I am saving one specific thing to
address on the back half but I want to
talk about the rest of it first because
even separate from that one
thing I think there's plenty to talk
about here and I'm going to do that so
we open with our introduction or
reintroduction if you're a massive
classic Who uh fan and I say massive
because the celestial toy maker where
the character that Neil Patrick Harris
is playing originates from is a lost
episode I believe they're now working on
an animated uh Recreation of it but this
is not an episode A lot of people are
familiar with outside of maybe reading a
Wiki about it it's one of those things
that's a bit harder to find even if you
like classic doctor well I say harder to
find the actual episodes you can't find
it all until we have the animated
Recreation but you know there were
things that you could look up there were
some still images there was audio there
were things like that but that's not a
lot to go on and not everybody is up for
just that kind of stuff without the full
context of the thing so he's an
interesting pull already and the other
thing that the episode addresses pretty
headon as it goes along is that he also
dates back to a time in Doctor Who where
how grounded Doctor Who as a show was
meant to be in reality for a better for
a lack of a better way to put it wasn't
as solid yet even early on the show
Mostly leaned on science and not a ton
on outright fantasy but there were
episodes like this uh the second doctor
story The Mind robber where the doctor
and his companions are literally trapped
in the land of fiction that kind of gets
a sci-fi-ish explanation later but it's
also the kind of concept that like
modern Doctor Who wouldn't touch this is
too it's too fairy tale it's it's too
this doesn't work with the level of
grounded we've gone for like Doctor Who
has never been scientifically sound at
any point but it has had an internal
logic that's been relatively consistent
especially since the reboot in 2005 and
a character like toy maker breaks it by
his nature and how he operates and the
fact that there isn't really a valid
scientific explanation for what he can
do and they roll with that I like that a
lot but I started talking about Neil
Patrick Harris he is clearly having so
much fun with this part and I normally
say that as a praise in general I think
it's a good thing uh you know barring a
piece meant to be super serious and DOW
but like if something's meant to have a
sense of fun to it it always feels nice
when the actors feel like they are
having as well I consider that a
positive kind of almost objectively at
least to my taste which means it's not
really objective but you get what I mean
that's something that I think is a good
thing under most circumstances but it's
especially important here because kind
of the point of the toy maker is he does
this for fun he's not trying to take
over the universe or white people out he
has no mations there's no philosophy
behind this this isn't Davos you know
who wants to feel the power within his
hand to destroy everything just to know
that he could this isn't the Dolex who
are fundamentally against everything
that is not them this isn't the Cybermen
who have this undercurrent philosophy of
everything that can be made into us
should be we are superior there's none
of that he's just doing it because it's
fun so it is vital that it come across
that this character is having a blast
because if he's not why do it and the
thing is I could see a version of this
character who's much more Dow and like
make make him into more of an obsessive
about games where it's less about fun
and it's more of a compulsion you could
do that I like this better though I like
just leaning into the idea of he does
this for fun let him have fun right down
to lip sinking to freaking Spice Girls
and dancing all over unit and I love I
love the little moment from the doctor
that kind of address his head on the
fact that you can't explain him by
normal rules CU he has his quick
exchange with Shirley if I told you he
manipulates atoms with a power of
thought would you believe it is that
what he
does if you want to think that so we can
move forward sure go with that but no he
doesn't obey the same rules which I just
like I understand why this kind of
Loosey Goosey nature is not standard in
Doctor Who anymore and I'm not saying it
should be become standard but I like
that they do just enough of a
justification for why this is the case
here I think Neil Patrick Harris has a
lot of fun with it uh the shifting
accents I found kind of interesting your
accent seems so
slit I hope the kitties enjoy him um I'm
not I don't know if there's meant to be
a reason why the German is the one who
goes to most frequently but like he
drops it for British a few times he goes
American at some Point like especially
when he's chastising the doctor about
the companions he's lost and the doctor
you know has the little asteris that
most of these companions have had so
they haven't been totally tragic you
know that Clara still lives in the last
second of her life that Bill's
Consciousness lives on and the toy maker
just goes oh well that's all right then
very American so my read on the
different accents is it's just part of
the game it's just him con it's part of
his having fun I'll talk this way cuz
this is fun to me right now and maybe
I'll switch to this accent cuz I'll feel
like that's fun he can be fickle he's
Bound by the rules of whatever game he's
playing but things like how he talks
those aren't bound to rules of games so
he can just be as fickle as he wants
what feels like fun German right now
German feels like fun so that's my read
on it at least that's a phrase you're
going to hear a couple times as I talk
about this episode my read and my
interpretation on a a few things because
again some things especially when we get
to the thing that I'm holding off on uh
we will get to it but you know there's a
fair number of things that sat right
with me but also because I have a
certain amount of interpretation that I
bring to it that is a little bit extra
textual meaning it is not 100% explicit
within the body of the episode Oh and
before we get any further I should note
this at time of recording I know there
is available a behind the scenes segment
it's about 15 minutes on the Doctor Who
Channel um and I've also heard that like
there's some other stuff out there that
has Russell T Davis
talking about some of the thought
process and talking about how some
things like would work I have not seen
any of that and that's on purpose
because I want what views I give you
here to be based only on the text of the
episode itself I will check those things
out later and if after I've seen them I
feel that they are worth delving into
more maybe I'll do another video or if
it's something I can throw together
quickly maybe I'll do it as a short no
promises but understand that whatever
opinion you hear from me is based
strictly off my viewing of this and more
to the point if you put down in the
comments well what you said and your
read on this is wrong cuz RTD said
this I'm not trying to be rude about
this but I don't care
uh I brought this up when I talked about
the Davos thing with children in need
interviews are not canon and while in
that one I did still talk about a little
bit because it is possible that
interviews and what is said in
interviews could be an indication of
what may be Canon later and what might
be intended but in and of themselves
they're not canon because if you are
going to counter anything that I have
about my interpretation or my beliefs or
my hopes with what RTD said that is not
within Canon I am not really going to
address it because just because he said
it again that just indicates his
intention that doesn't mean that he's
actually going to force it to be Canon
later either he might he might not again
interviews are not canon all right so
the toy maker I like the interactions
and the energy that he brings
particularly when interacting directly
with tenant I think he brings I I
actually kind of like Neil p Caris when
he does kind of medicine characters he
was quite good in The Matrix
Resurrection which just as a reminder
was a way better movie than most of you
acted like it was but I like when he
brings the sense of Menace but also that
sense of fun which he does really well
and counteracted by the doctor who is
taking this all very seriously go back
to the
Tardis you never tell me to do that and
I love the doctor initially trying to
take him on just with the cutting of the
deck because he has the ace up his
sleeve of best two out of three which
was very clever but what I like about
that is he's rolling the
dice there is even odds that he will win
right now and this whole thing will be
over it isn't and we move on to his
safety net that he already figured out
best two out of three but I just like
that he was willing to roll those dice I
like that that was good uh the puppet
imagery was was decently creepy I'd say
like here's the thing I've said before
that I don't find old old style puppets
or dolls particularly creepy in and of
themselves it's part of why some of the
inherent creepiness that really got
people about night terrors didn't really
work on me because I just don't find
those dolls that creepy I will say that
with the puppets they leaned into the
creepy Nature by the way they acted not
just the fact like oh marionette little
bit of a
little bit of a ventriloquist dummy
thing going no like the way that they
behaved and the thing that it said like
especially the uh the Widow puppet I
guess
I'm I don't know what to do it made it a
bit more creepy not in a way that
actually actively creeped me out but I'm
like see this is more effective than
just showing me a creepy doll and be
like doesn't this creepy out I'm like no
you have to actually do something creepy
with it which this does so I did like
that and the uh the humanized mannequin
especially when it was briefly the
doctor I thought I was good imagery
solid I like it and I I loves me a non-
ukian maze you go through a door it
doesn't go where it should and you try
to go back through it it doesn't take
you to where you were before they become
a mild cliche thanks to a lot of video
games like um layers of fear or even PT
uh going back to that but it's still
effective if you can do it well and this
this does it well and doesn't lean on it
too hard where it gets old it does it
for just long enough that it's effective
and also despite some people telling me
in the comments of the previous one that
you know what Donna said she didn't
remember all the doctor's history and
that it must have just been in the not
things brain and she can't hold it uh
Fair number of people said you know what
I think she actually does remember is
just being nice to him that didn't sit
right with me I didn't reply to those
comments that didn't sit right with me
because I'm like I don't think they're
at a point where she's going to lie to
him to spare his feelings like I
understand she'd be gentle but I don't
think she'd lie to him and I got a nice
confirmation on that because it has to
be reiterated to her through you know
the little Mary in that show talking
about Amy claraa Bill the flux she
doesn't remember she actually asked the
question is one of this true and again
bringing up the flux again and giving
more weight to the consequences of the
thing that chimel did that he just
ignored the consequences on so
again I like that being reiterated I'm
not entirely positive that the having
the salt Superstition at the edge of the
universe was a necessary move for
bringing in the toy maker I mean it
works well enough I cast that Su at the
edge of the Universe I played the game
and let him in I think it would have
personally at least worked a little
better for me if it wasn't the episode
immediately following if like there had
been some time between I know in this
case that wasn't going to happen David
Tennant was only doing the three
specials so like that was never going to
be the case but I don't know I feel like
that plant and payoff would have landed
a little bit better for me and felt a
little bit more clever if I'd had the
time to forget that that happened and
then bringing it back later bring it
back immediately after like it's like oh
yeah okay yeah sure that works why not
so since I'm already talking about the
toy maker let's talk about the Giggle
and how it operates cuz the more I
thought about it the more I liked it now
this is also where we're going to get a
little bit into my interpretations of
how all this works not necessarily the
intended Cannon of how it works because
I'm going to zero in on Kate Lethbridge
Stewart to explain what I mean by this I
really like the way that the toy maker
explains it why does everyone think
they're right so that they win I made
every opinion Supreme everybody just
thinks that they're right on their first
impulses because that way
they'll always try to
win that framing giving Humanity that
perspective of you're either winning or
you're losing see normally dropping a
line about like cancel culture which is
dropped in there a little bit that's the
game of the 21st century they shout and
they type and they cancel that would
normally annoy me this is actually a
time where like it's not making a huge
thing out of it but dropping that if
this is the point you're making that
humans when they are forced into a
mindset of you are right and you have to
go out and prove it and you have to win
on the fact that you're right otherwise
you lose forcing that to be the lens
through which we view the world yeah
that does feed into a lot of the most
toxic Behavior particularly online
behavior and tying that through a single
line to cancel culture without turning
it into a hole and cancel culture is
terrible and here's all these examples
of it cuz that's often where things get
really dicey but just acknowledging it
is like yeah it's it can very easily is
not necessarily always in my view but
can very easily become part of a we have
to win um and the other side has to lose
and we're drawing battle lines and we're
making this uh Zero Sum game of win or
lose yeah it it feeds into the toxic
side of human nature so I said I was
going to zero in on Kate so here's what
I really like about what they used to
illustrate with her these things that
she says that that she is distrusting of
the doctor because he's an alien we've
been infiltrated by aliens by a man with
two hearts a man who changes his face
and cannot be trusted and also the stuff
that she says towards shely I'll focus
on that a little more specifically in a
minute but what I like about that is
that my read on this is that it is
basically locking people in to dying on
the hill of their gut instinct in their
Bas level responses and I'll try and
explain what I mean by that for Kate it
makes total sense regardless of how much
time she spent with the doctor working
with the doctor given that she is the
daughter of the Brigadier that she
herself has been fighting aliens for
most of her life her natural gut
instinct is going to be distrust now
normally when working with the doctor
she overcomes that initial distrust with
the you know reminding yourself okay but
he's on our side he helps us he's thing
but at the core underneath that is still
that seed of
xenophobia that fear of the other that
distrust of the other and what the
giggle appears to have done is remove
the higher layer of brain functions that
look at the gut reaction she has and go
okay wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute that doesn't apply here or that's
not helpful so here's what I've said
elsewhere that I'm going to reiterate
here and I've said this often times
talking with people who are working on
getting better about certain aspects of
how they view the world and treat other
people and often times they will have a
lot of concerns because they'll still
have that seed they'll still have that
initial thought in their head that is
racist sexist homophobic
Etc and when I say people I'm not
strictly saying people who aren't me no
no no I've had to deal with this
too what I've said in those cases is you
are not fully
responsible for your gut instinct or
your first emotional reaction to
something because of what you have been
through in your life and the society
that you have been raised in and the
environment around you your initial gut
reaction is something that you will have
very little control over and you are not
fully responsible for having an initial
gut in your head
reaction that is racist sexist
homophobic Etc and like I say for the
most part like if you haven't been
trying to work on that and you're just
letting it happen that's a problem but
that kind of gets the second part of
what I tend to tell people you are not
fully solely responsible for that
initial thought that is carrying that
seed of something that you know is wrong
you're not fully responsible for that
because it is a gut instinct that's
going to take a very long time to get
rid of if it's even possible to do it
all but what you absolutely are
responsible for is what you do as a
result of that gut
reaction because one of the least he
things that can happen is somebody
encounters something or sees something
and has a bigoted thought in their head
about it and then goes oh gosh I'm such
a terrible person I still think that oh
what wrong with me like you're not
helping anybody doing that you're not
helping yourself you're not helping
anybody else and you're not getting
better what you can do is go okay would
have been nice if I hadn't had that
thought but here's why I know it's wrong
your higher brain functions go okay yeah
that was a thought I'm not proud of but
I don't have to act on it here's why
it's wrong here's why I'm not going to
say that here's what I know that
overrides improves that gut instinct
that I can't fully control wrong you're
not responsible for your first gut
reaction but you are responsible for
whether or not you act on it or Tamp it
down and I don't mean like in a
repression way I
mean take into account what it is you're
doing and not just take your first
impulse and go this is the Hill I will
die on and that is my read on what the
giggle is it removes that that higher
level that sort of checks
imbalance so that whatever your initial
gut response is you just do that so hard
so for Kate with the doctor he's an
alien and aliens are harmful to us
doesn't get tampered by what would be
her normal brain function which is but I
know the doctor but he's helped us but
but the there isn't time for that those
aren't allowed to come in and we see
that also with her interactions with
Shirley accusing Shirley of not actually
being disabled and as for her in that
chair I've seen you w I've seen you
walking don't deny it and that was
really well done and I I had already
Loved Before that that they showed her
get up out of the chair and stand at a
console because
given the depictions we are normally
shown of disabled people such as
wheelchair users is that they are always
in this this is the only way they get
around when the reality is there are
many people who make use of Mobility
AIDS be the be they wheelchairs or
anything else where they are not 100%
all the time restricted to this some of
them can stand up some of them can even
walk to some degree but what they can't
do is engage with the degree of walking
that Society is built around assuming
that they can do that's what they can't
do they may not have the stamina in
their legs they may not have the
coordination whatever it might be that
is limiting them that doesn't mean they
can't stand that doesn't mean they can't
take some steps and if they can stand
and can take some steps that does not
mean they're faking it but because our
media depictions generally rolls with
the idea of well you're in a wheelchair
that's it that's all you're ever going
to be
it makes people react the way that Kate
reacts when she's not having those
higher functions calming her down which
is I've seen you get up so you're faking
it and to be clear this doesn't just
impact people who use Mobility AIDS this
is an issue for people who are deaf for
people who are blind you can be
designated legally deaf or legally blind
without being totally deaf or totally
blind and because maybe you are legally
blind in in the sense that okay we know
you should not be allowed to operate uh
a car or you know you need these
assistances in order to get through life
for both your safety and the safety of
others but they'll notice that someone's
waving at them and then some jackass
will go ah you're not blind like no they
could see the shape they responded to a
shape but not well enough that they
could function the way someone who
doesn't have any issues with their site
or can have their site more or less
fully corrected by
lenses they can't do what those people
will do and society's built on the
assumption that your site is at a
certain base level and if theirs is so
far below that then that does not mean
they see literally nothing but it means
they can't see well enough to function
the way the rest of us function and
similarly with heart of hearing doesn't
mean you can't hear literally anything
it just means you can't do it well
enough for whatever reason without
Assistance or possibly not at all to be
able to function and the way the society
is constructed on the Assumption you can
do those things so I already loved the
fact that Shirley stood up and just very
subtly initially addressed that Core
Fact of people with disability but then
to see Kate who knows her and appears to
respect her and is horrified once she
gets her senses back at what she has
done sh I'm so sorry I think that was a
good organic way to draw attention to
this entire issue with a character that
I was already enjoying from her first
appearance in starbeast and I like that
it feeds into demonstrating how the
giggle works so it's not Superfluous
it's giving us two examples so we know
it's not unique to the doctor she has a
xenophobic reaction to the doctor and an
ableist reaction towards Shirley so we
get multiple examples to get an idea of
how this thing freaking works and I
think it is well done and well
integrated into the story and anyone who
says it's just there for pandering
obviously does not understand how you
weave these things into story like look
things can be done incredibly clunkily
and feel forc and be like why was that
even there I know why this is here it is
demonstrating in two ways because I
think it is important to do it in more
than just one just to really make the
point of how this work it's
demonstrating in two ways what the
giggle does to people and it is using
the open opportunity of that to
demonstrate a problem that exists in
society that to me is well- integrated
writing that is very soundly integrating
a societal Point into a story that
benefits from you making that point I
think this is all really well done since
we're on the topic of
Shirley the ramp at the end showing the
tartis is wheelchair accessible that is
really nice because I didn't clock this
at first when we first saw the new
TARDIS in starbeast other people point
out in my comments it's all ramps which
means someone who makes use of a
wheelchair can move around in there I
didn't clock that in I was like oh cool
but funnily enough again because I'm not
disabled and I have blind spots around
this my Mobility does not require
assistance so it didn't occur to me that
even though the interior was navigable
by use of a wheelchair that there was
still that bump there's still that step
up and now there's a little ramp to flip
out it wouldn't have occurred to me that
the tartis needed that as well and of
course it wouldn't have occurred to me I
don't need a Mobility Aid so I have
blind spots this was a little bit that I
did catch some a little tiny bit of
behind the scenes because evidently some
things noted by fans of the show who are
wheelchair users that found its way to
RTD he actually told me about a fan who'
contacted him who was a wheelchair user
and said how much she admired Russ's
work he said even though I can't get in
the Tardis because it's not wheelchair
accessible and he didn't want them to
feel excluded like they couldn't also
travel in the Tardis this is a tiny
thing that just means the show is
opening up and embracing and allowing a
portion of the audience that previously
had a certain barrier to the idea that
they could be the companion or they
could be the doctor as
themselves that barrier is now gone I
see that only as a positive thing you
finally C over the 21st century so the
other thing I want to talk about the
giggle is that it also gets us some
interesting moments with this doctor
with the 14th doctor because he does
something that I like seeing when it's
done well and like this can go either
way for me so he notes that you know
human beings for all your
Brilliance you've got a lot of problems
under the surface you've got a lot of
Base
instincts that are there that sometimes
you don't overcome and all those are
running rampant all the anger out there
on the street the lies the righteousness
that's human that's you that's who you
are using your intelligence to be stupid
this is nice for me to see particularly
coming from a doctor with David tenant's
face so it can go to either extreme for
me um and not work for me in both cases
although not to the same degree I'll get
to that a second the idea of the doctor
blanketly condemning humans or blanketly
praising humans in terms of blanketly
condemning that tends to bother me a
little bit less cuz usually when that
happens like say when the Ninth Doctor
made a general complaint about you know
stupid Apes I did it again I picked
another stupid ape that came at a moment
where he was just emotionally frustrated
I understood why he said that and didn't
necessarily feel core to how he viewed
people in the Ninth Doctor was in a d
place anyways but then there's the Other
Extreme which we saw from characters
like the 10th doctor relatively
frequently not exclusively the 10th
doctor but we did see it a fair bit with
the 10th doctor this whole thing oh
humans oh you're so brilliant and you're
so wonderful I love this and this and
this and this about you human beings you
are amazing that used to really bug me I
mean I say used to it didn't stop
bugging me but it it happens less often
or at least I notice it less often as
time has gone on but that really did
annoy me because look I don't think
there's a problem with the doctor again
especially tenants doctor um who didn't
think he had a home in galr anymore at
the time uh to have a very strong
affinity for Humanity I think there's
nothing wrong with him having a soft
spot and enjoying humans I do kind of
have a problem with him a grandis them
and talking about them like they're
somehow the most special thing ever
sometimes it can work like in the end of
time part two we must look like insects
to
you I think you look like giants that
does work because of the specific
Framing and him talking to that
character in particular that works side
note real quick wil I know we couldn't
get Bernard cribbons back for this we
were stuck with a body double in the
opening scene but I also really like
that they have the dialogue that he's in
the he's in the garden shooting at moles
but here we
are no I like the acknowledgement that
he's still there that he's not gone and
that was kind of all they could do and
I'm glad that they did it so it still
felt like there was a presence there
even though the actor sadly passed away
and could not appear so anyway coming
back so like that conversation he has
with wil and that Felts less overall
ganizing because it feeds into the fact
that in a little bit that doctor the
tenth doctor was going to sacrifice
himself to save wi so it was kind of
important in that story to reiterate the
idea that he doesn't think he's above
humanity and he sees a lot of Beauty in
them but there are other times where
he'll just go off on like oh humans look
at you out there doing all this and it
it just bugs me like for all the things
you've seen all the species planets all
over space in time if you are implying
that we are as good as it gets that's
real
depressing like you can have a soft spot
for something and also not think it's
the best thing ever I am more okay with
the idea that humanity is the doctor's
guilty pleasure than like something that
he thinks is wonderful and amazing which
is how he has frequently acted at
various points in the past and again not
exclusively the tenant doctor but it
happened a fair bit under him but to
have have him in particular acknowledge
this other side of humanity the human
race might be clever and bright and
Brilliant it's also Savage and V and
Relentless and especially because it
doesn't feel like he's saying it in a
way that negates any of the praise he's
given but it's his acknowledgement here
that yeah you guys can be amazing but
boy boy you've got some
issues cuz
yeah yeah individually and collectively
yeah we do good good the blind praising
of human beings by oh not just the
doctor by aliens in general it's a
little bit of a Sci-Fi Trope it comes up
every now and then where you like you'll
just get non-human species being like Oh
yes I truly admire humans they have this
that no other species have I'm like BS
nonsense I don't buy that for a second
you're just finding an excuse to make
humans look like the best thing and
please tell me we're not so so that was
a moment that I just liked that that
felt like it was there for me almost and
actually since we've kind of touched on
it now I want to address the idea of how
this doctor is admittedly in some ways
different from the 10th I had kind of
mentioned previously I think in both
episodes that I didn't see a huge
difference between this doctor and the
10th doctor and I've gotten push back on
that in both of my previous two reviews
and I want to clarify exactly where my
headp space was at cuz I think to a
certain degree people were like looking
at this Doctrine thinking of I don't
know Series 2 Series 3 heck even series
4 Doctrine going well no this one's
quite a bit different he's gentler he's
softer he's easy he opens up easier he's
more inclined to say that he loves
someone like okay yes that's all true
but what I meant more was not that he's
behaving exactly like ten but what he is
doing is behaving as I would expect ten
to have developed if he hadn't
regenerated when he did taking the
experiences from the End of Time Parts
one and two and continuing on regardless
of whether he had the exact same
experiences as the other incarnations
but moving forward from that if David
Tennant just stayed in the part this
whole
time this is kind of how I would have
expected him to end up as eventually so
that's a little bit more what I meant
unless that he feels exactly like 10 but
more like yeah this feels like if 10 had
stuck around but I think that I see the
value in doing that in this episode
pretty well I saw some value in it in
the previous episode in wild blue yonder
because you really needed that
established dynamic between the doctor
and Donna for so much of that episode to
work at all and having the doctor be
more distinctly different which was my
gut instinct for what I wanted um that
Dynamic wouldn't have worked at all if
he was completely different in his
behavior um in general like I still like
the idea of a doctor with a pre-existing
face but a different personality I still
kind of like that as a notion but that's
not what they did and what they've done
does play much better if he feels very
connected to the 10th doctor which
especially stuff that goes on towards
the tail end and yes I promise we will
get there that feels like this is doing
stories that benefit from him feeling
fundamentally in my opinion like the
10th doctor or at least like an
evolution of the 10th doctor these
stories benefit from that which is good
because if you're going to take an idea
that I am resistant to the very least
you could do is use that idea to tell
stories that you couldn't tell if you
didn't use that idea hold on to that
notion we will be coming back to it but
the last thing that I think I will say
before we get um to the big spoiler
stuff and the thing I know you've all
been waiting to hear my opinion on time
dying into the fact that this doctor
feels quite a bit like the tenth but
also a bit different he has his
confrontation with the toy maker and he
doesn't do what 10 usually did which is
to issue a warning which is to say you
need to stop or I will take you apart
why would I leave this place because if
you don't I'll have to stop you instead
he offers a hand in Friendship we can
take your games back to the
Stars we can play across the cosmos he
offers to travel with the toy maker with
no threat no if you don't I will do X
just come with me and we'll we'll play
the games will be across the stars now
this is not the first time he's done
that he did that with the master we
could travel the Stars it would be my
honor cuz you don't need to own the
universe just see it that was a
character that he had a very specific
and at one point previously friendly
history his he's now extending that
level of empathy and offer to just we
don't have to fight and not again not in
a threat way not in a I know what I'll
have to do if you turn me down way just
as a way to try and bring an end to this
he's offering that to someone who has
only ever been his
enemy I like that as an evolution for
him there was one other thing to touch
on quickly Mel showing up um is fine I
don't feel like there is as much dug
into with her as they did with say ace
or Teegan in power of the doctor but
then again Mel's onscreen appearances
there isn't as much to deal with um
there were little acknowledgements of
her past I like the mention of sabong
Glitz and it was decently done she
doesn't add a ton by her presence but
she also doesn't detract and if you're
someone who in is increasingly enjoying
classic who then yeah she's a fun
addition but she doesn't need to be
there but she's not a focus either so
she's a unnecessary but fun
addition but okay let's talk about the
thing the by
Generation
boy yeah yeah okay so this is a whole
thing and it took me a little while to
figure out my thoughts on this and I
also did something that I normally don't
do something that I very deliberately do
not do when I do these well honestly
reviews on most things unless I'm
getting to something very late and I had
no way of of avoiding what the general
opinion of it is that happened with say
Barbie um unless that happens especially
with something that I'm planning to see
right off I do not see other people's
reviews before I sit down to shoot my
own and I held true to that but I bent
it a teeny bit I did after seeing it bum
around Twitter a little bit to kind of
gauge General reaction to this now I was
very careful to spend very little time
on this I didn't dive down a rabbit hole
cuz I didn't want want to get the full
brunt of the discourse so what I found
and this was very handy was crispy Pro
who is another Doctor Who Focus YouTuber
who's very good by the way and who um I
enjoy his work and I feel like he and I
are often on the same page not
necessarily in terms of our preferences
or what we like or don't like but the
fact that I think we both largely
approach the show is something that we
always want to like whether or not we do
so knowing that knowing him and knowing
that's the kind of uh he cultivates
checking when he put out a tweet asking
what do people think of this and just
browsing through the replies on that and
doing it relatively early before it had
the possibility to you know turn into
just toxicity which it's Twitter that
can happen regardless of what the fandom
is or what anybody says but what I saw
there was a fair number of people
basically amounting to I liked it up
until the buy generation or people going
like I don't know what I feel about
about the by generation so this at least
from my Quick Glance which was all I was
willing to do before sitting down to
shoot this people seem a little bit
divided on this and I do get why if you
are very much into the logistics the
mechanics and the continuity and
preserving Cannon then yeah this is
going to bug you you know there would
have been a time not too long ago where
I might have made a joke like if
continuity and being consistent matters
that much to you why you're even
watching Doctor cuz this Show's never
been good about that and that is true
but I'm not doing anybody ever any
favors by pretending that an audience
who cares about this doesn't exist I
know them I've met them in my comments
and at conventions I know that there is
a fandom that as inconsistent as the
show has been that the way that they
approach this and possibly other media
as well they still want a certain amount
of consistency they want things to
behave by the rules that as they
understand them and I'm not immune to
that myself my own General thing is I
don't need things to match reality but I
would like it if you would adhere to the
rules you have established and if you're
going to break them please tell me why
that is my general base level and for me
and for my looking at and interpreting
this I do feel that there is something
that at least for me Works which is yes
the um toy maker can
do all these things that break all the
rules all the laws of physics the laws
of reality as we know them and in My
Mind by his presence the rules are a
little
influx kind of for everything what if
the toy maker domain is still lingering
just for a few seconds while we're in a
state of play not fully not like
anything could happen but like something
that otherwise
as the 15th doctor shi's doctor says
shouldn't be possible and is only a myth
I have by generated there's no such
thing by generation is supposed to be a
myth it could happen now now is it a
little bit of a cop out to be like well
this is a mythological thing it's never
happened before like since
when that is a little bit of you know
pulling it out of your rear end but I
think just having the toy maker present
and the nature of what he is and how he
operates to me just having him there
makes the rules flexible enough that I'm
okay with this happening this time in
terms of like regeneration has never
worked like this before now normally
that would bother me but in this case I
feel like that explanation at least for
me in my head
works that having been said on
paper I really would have said this is a
bad
idea because first of all the general
idea of having two doctors interacting
with each other in a way that isn't
acknowledged as breaking the rules of
time and space and it isn't a case of
like tenants doctor is lingering but
he's only going to last a short amount
of time or it's not happening at the
edge which was introduced in the power
of doctor and is a cool idea and you
know we're not doing any of that they're
just both existing no don't do that
that's a really bad idea that is
just begging for people to continually
demand the return of tenant's doctor and
to just say forever boy the show would
have been so great if he just stayed on
they they kept that doctor around why
didn't they and like fans may or may not
still do that but like if you were just
to tell me the idea I would look at it
and go I don't see what we gain and it's
just going to cause so many headaches
and so many arguments can this possibly
be worth it and and here's the funny
thing I think it
is because kind of like what I said
before you can do something that I think
is a bad idea but if you do something
with it that you couldn't have done
otherwise and that thing is worth doing
brings me joy if I see this thing I go
okay I enjoy that and you couldn't have
done it if you hadn't done this thing
that I thought was a bad
idea that can work
and it does here in a number of ways
there's there is a little bit of kind of
the campy goofiness of the visual of
them being pulled apart and then they're
each in half of the outfit which took me
a second to realize that that is what
had happened ah dang it I had meant to
meant to let my hair down for this
half I suppose the uh the question
people are really wondering is uh am am
I not wearing proper trousers I don't
know what did that sound like we do
authenticity around here anyways yeah
the visual is a little bit on the silly
side it's RTD doing Doctor Who you kind
of have to deal with a certain amount of
that um and it's made it's been made
clear over the course of these three
specials that yes he's not going to
abandon some of his goofier campier
instincts in regards to the show but
when I say that this does something that
could not have happened if not not for
the choice to do the by generation here
is what I mean this becomes a vehicle to
do something that the show could never
do unless the show was ending and I mean
permanently it gives a doctor a happy
ending I've never been so happy in my
life that can't
happen because any other time to have a
doctor and have them settle and be happy
and just live and not feel the need to
Gallivan about and run away from their
own
baggage that would mean the show's over
because the doctor's no longer going
about having adventures all the dang
time so what's the show at that point
the show has to be over that has to be
how you end the entire thing and
honestly I've said in the past my uh
notion for the perfect way to end the
show if anybody ever did decide to end
it permanently would be to have the
doctor whatever Incarnation is around at
that point to go and see Susan his
granddaughter who when he left her when
the first doctor left her said one day I
shall come back yes I shall come back
and I would say going with her and
settling in and saying I'm done
traveling I'm home would be the way to
end the whole show and this basically
does that with the equivalent of of the
10th doctor again I know he's the 14th
is a little bit different behaviorally
but having him settle with Donna feels
emotionally to me the same vein as
having the first or any incarnation of
the doctor go back to Susan and you
can't do that without ending the show or
undoing it one of two things would have
to happen if they attempted to do this
in any other way either the show would
have to
end and inevitably because we live in a
time when franchises are not allowed to
die somebody would bring it back either
by injecting all these interstitial
stuff and like oh well here was a
regeneration you didn't know about
happened in between and then it's
effectively like the show hasn't ended
or by just undoing the happy ending and
sending the doctor off again and then
it's like what was the point but he can
have it he can have the happy ending the
family he still has his Tardis but
because there's another doctor who is
clearly demonstrably super eager to go
out and have adventures and go out and
save the
universe this one doesn't have to the
things that would drive him to always
keep going and never slow
down don't have to apply to him anymore
he doesn't have to worry what about all
the planets in danger the what if the
universe is in Jeopardy the doctor is
going to take care of
that and even what gets addressed in
this episode this idea of I have to keep
running cuz if I slow down all the
sadness hits what am I what am I
now this doctor is not self-reflecting
because he won't stop moving he's not
even really pausing to have a proper
conversation with Donna he's just moving
as fast as he
can because slowing
down might mean at least for this
Incarnation not necessarily every
Carnation but but in this Incarnation
slowing down might mean realizing how
unhappy he is doing what he's doing and
realizing he'd like to stop but also
giving him a tardis so that yeah he can
take Rose to a jaunt to Mars he can do a
quick thing here or there he took me to
New York last week the Gilded Age it was
amazing well where the Tardis becomes
like a camper van it's something you you
load the family into and have a little
holiday but you don't live in it
you don't have to constantly be
traveling it's there for when you need
it but you can
relax you can just have a
home there has never been the
opportunity to tell that story on this
show and I don't know of any way you
could have done it without doing
something like this and I'm sure some
will argue with me well what about the
metac crisis doctor that version of the
10th doctor got to have Rose and was
given in theory the ability to create
his own tardis and is moving all about
that Universe isn't that kind of a happy
ending for that version of the doctor
that we never saw again sure it is but
there was still the tinge of sadness on
it because the one we followed back to
our universe still had to deal with the
weight and the loss what this whole
thing allows us to do is have a
regeneration without the tragedy because
no matter how excited you are for any
new doctor be it Shy gowa or anybody
else and I will talk a little bit about
his performance in particular again let
me get through stuff this is a long one
if you hadn't guessed already what is
really nice about this is no matter how
excited you are about a doctor normally
there's that sense of loss but this
other one's gone we get just once to
have a
regeneration without the sadness and I
think there was a time 15 years ago or
so where I would have said like but the
sadness is powerful don't do it without
the sadness and I'm not saying I want
this to become the template I'm not
saying I ever want this to happen ever
again but just once funny thing is I
fought all those battles for all those
years and now I know what
for this to let it
be the happiest version of a
regeneration it can be
where Donna and her family aren't left
mourning a version of the doctor that
died where we don't have to see him
gone where the audience doesn't have to
mourn and also just get to enjoy the
excitement of a new
doctor that's
magical and this is what I mean this is
this is the perfect version of having
your cake and eating it too because
we're getting the excitement of the new
doctor and we're getting this happy
ending but as I said normally the only
way to get an ending like this would be
to end the show but we get it here and
the show doesn't have to end more
adventures and I'm sure some people are
going to go well yeah but you know
they're going to bring him back because
he's still hanging around here's the
thing I'm not so sure about that because
I assume that about the metac crisis
doctor I had assumed for so long oh they
created this other version of the doctor
just so they can bring David tenant back
at a later point but then eventually
when they did bring David David Tenant
back they didn't do it with the metac
crisis doctor I
normally would make that same kind of
assumption like oh well they're just
gonna they're just GNA have him come
back at a later time and you know
they're going to like I don't know I
don't know because I assumed that before
and I was wrong I assumed that with this
writer and I was
wrong and if somebody can prove me wrong
on something that I was dead certain
about that was very much in the same
vein I'm not taking it as a given that
we're going to see this doctor again I
am going to hope that this he just gets
to have his happy ending I I know there
will be some people who say well he
should come back the same way there are
some people who are like Marvel should
bring back Tony Stark and and Steve
Rogers no they shouldn't they had their
endings let them have their endings let
this doctor have his ending it finally
wasn't a sad one let him have it and I
have a certain amount of faith that that
will be allowed to
stand and if it turns out later that
they do bring him back I'll probably be
annoyed but for right
now not not really feeling comfortable
and assuming that that will definitely
happen this just feels good this just
feels wonderful and this kind of having
your cake and eating it too is really
hard to pull off because Davies himself
has failed at it before Series 3 the
whole thing with Martha and the uh the
two-parter that ended that where like
hlane come down and that was also an
attempt to like disrupt the doctor's
faith in humanity but it didn't stick he
went right back to praising Humanity all
over the place right after that so that
felt like it didn't stick that tried to
have it its cake and eat it too by
having this massive decimation of the
human population humans living for a
year under complete uh Domination by the
tofane and the master and then at the
end of it everything rolls back and just
a handful of people remember it all that
was a kind of having your cake and
eating it too that is much more common
that is usually what you get because it
wanted to have the much higher Stakes
but then not have the full consequences
and like if you're going to roll back
most of the consequences nearly all of
the consequences of what it was you did
then why'd you do it now there are ways
around that but I don't think that story
did it successfully here this is having
your cake and eating it to to in the
best way because it's not about avoiding
anything it's about letting us have
something that we couldn't have any
other way to see the
doctor at a at a table in a garden
having dinner with a with an adopted
family that's
beautiful just
once let him have it the by
generation is a wonky
idea but to compare it to one that drove
me
crazy so is the Timeless child the
difference is the Timeless child not
only didn't result in a story that
couldn't be told otherwise it arguably
didn't result in any stories at all
there was almost nothing built off that
idea there was almost nothing done with
that idea this it is an idea that I do
not ever want to see repeated I do not
want this to become the standard of how
regeneration works I do not care if the
tenant doctor can regenerate into
somebody else I don't want that ever to
be brought up again just leave it alone
I don't want the rolling consequences of
this I want it to be its own nice
isolated thing so I am still like iffy
about this ever happening again but for
this time within this isolation right
now at time of
talking I like this as much as I think
that's a bad idea you built something
beautiful that you couldn't build
without the foundation of that idea
whereas the Timeless child there was
almost nothing built on top of it and
the stories told after that Revelation
could have happened almost identically
without
it that's the
difference you can do something that I
think is a bad idea and turn me around
on it not because I suddenly think it's
a better idea I still think within just
looking at the notion I still think the
idea of by generation is a bad idea but
dang it Davies you built Something
Beautiful with it you made something
that we wouldn't have gotten and we
couldn't see otherwise and I got to give
it to you for that
that's
amazing all right so shiwa himself this
might be my one criticism of the episode
not that I don't I don't like how he
played it I like how he played it it had
a lot of energy great smile wonderful
presence I do feel I didn't get a full
sense of him yet because a lot of what
he was doing was playing off of tenants
doctor and I don't think that
necessarily takes away from goda's
doctor but it does kind of distract from
my ability to get a full read on him
that's not necessarily A Bad Thing most
doctors I didn't feel like I had a
proper read on in their first appearance
really the only ones where that has been
the case at least in the since the 2005
re uh Rebo is uh thing started was
eckl and Matt Smith within their first
appearances I felt like I got them right
off tenant took a little while Capaldi
took quite a while but he's now my
favorite um
Whitaker some sometimes she worked um
but that one I I it was a while before I
started to get an angle on her that
worked for me like more often than not I
don't fully settle on like feeling like
I get a doctor right away but I feel
like for how much screen time he get
yeah maybe I should have a better idea
than I do but I don't have that much of
an idea cuz I don't get to see him on
his own that concern is pretty heavily
mitigated by the fact that I'm going to
see him again in a pretty short amount
of time because he's got the Christmas
special if we were going to have to wait
like I don't know six months for his
first proper series or I guess they're
going to call this one a
season if I had to wait like 6 months
for that I'd be a little bit more
annoyed but I'm like I can wait a little
while to see what he's like on his own
and yes I have seen the very short
trailer for the Christmas special I
don't really have opinions on it there
isn't enough to go off of I'm excited
for it I want to see what he does but I
like the energy I like the energy that
he brought that's kind of all I have to
go on right now also because what makes
a doctor workable is not just who they
are but also the stories told with them
and this is far more the 14th doctor
story than the 15th so I can't really
gauge him on that BAS
yet I'll be able to at least start
trying to do so after the Christmas
special
so solid first appearance I like the
energy I don't have a uh fully settled
opinion yet but that's also pretty
typical for me with most doctors post
regeneration it usually takes me a
little while seriously though with
Capaldi it took me until his third
season to fully fall in love with him
but I did so we'll see how long it takes
couple of quick things that basically
amount to setup we have this whole thing
with like the essence of the master
contained in his tooth and then that
gets picked up by the end by a hand with
nail polish on it this is this is very
deliberately a call back because RTD
already did this with after the master
died at the end of Series 3 there was
the ring there was a hand that picked it
now I am sure I'm certain a ton of
people are already going to be
speculating it's the Ronnie and like at
this point it hasn't been the Ronnie for
so long as much as I don't really care
for the Ronnie I could see RTD going ah
it finally was but like he did jokingly
call that the hand of the Ronnie back
after Series 3 came out when ultimately
when he did bring back um the Johnson
Master he did something else with it so
don't assume that what don't assume
anything it will be the mechanism by
which the master comes back which Master
will it be no idea my gut instinct will
be new Incarnation because we don't know
which Incarnation the toy maker
encounters and trapped the essence of
it's possible that it is one we've
already seen it could be Dean it heck
the toy maker could have swept in and
recovered Missy as she was dying and
trapped her you could theoretically do
that I'm expecting it to be a new
Incarnation that's my gut instinct we'll
see down the line when this gets pulled
on and that might not necessarily be
done by RTD again I've been watching
this stuff long enough I do remember at
the time when Series 3 came out he said
that he didn't necessarily have a plan
for the master to come back but he still
planted that ring so that there would be
a way that the master could come back
should somebody decide to do it turned
out he decided to do it before he
finished up he may not actually be the
one to pick up the tooth thing but it's
there for whoever does whether it's him
or whether it's a future showrunner
again regardless of who it is I expect
probably new Incarnation there's also
the thing from the toy maker about the
one who Waits there's only one player I
didn't dare
face the one who Waits which presumably
also ties into what the Meep alluded to
about the boss
cryptic I ha that one is kind of led to
assume just because it would be really
weird if they were both referring to
something else um that those are one and
the same and I have have no theories uh
if you're new around here I'm real bad
at speculation my brain doesn't work
that way my brain rather than going like
o here's all the Deep lore and oh it
could be this and connect it to that and
here's here's the the conspiracy board
where it all connects like I can't
really do that because there's a part of
my brain that just goes just wait and
find out what it is why are you wasting
your mental energy on this so I very
rarely do speculation unless something
clicks which is pretty rare um so I
don't really have any speculation on
like o who could it be it could be
anything and I'd say it has at least as
good a chance of being something
completely new as it does being
something that we've seen before if I if
okay if it's going to be something that
we've seen before my gut instinct pull
would be Omega because he's one of the
few old school things of that degree of
power or at least close to it that you
could bring it back some might say like
the black Guardian except black Guardian
kind of got clowned on a bit uh in the
classic era enough that I I mean I guess
modern era hasn't seen him so I guess
maybe you could I don't know I I kind of
expected something else completely that
might be tied to something we've seen
but I I my guess is it's not actually
going to be something we've seen before
but what could it be I don't know I'm
going to wait around and find out that I
do expect to be something that Davies
himself answers I don't necessarily
expect him to be the one to follow up on
the tooth I do expect him to be the one
to follow up on the he who Waits which
it is funny to me that a lot of people
um especially who were frustrated uh
with Chris chiel's era as showrunner
kind of turned to lowkey especially its
first season is like see this this is
giving me the feelings that doctor who
isn't right now um and I do like Lok key
a lot I never quite connected to it on
that level but I will admit he who Waits
gives me a little bit of a taste of he
who remains I think I think it's just
the similar weighty language I don't
think there's meant to be an actual uh
connection drawn there but look we'll
see I don't really have a coherent
Theory so I think I think I think that's
everything wow I went on a long
time uh I don't know how long this is g
to end up like i' I've got to I've now
got to sit down and edit this thing H um
oh uh things that um I will follow up on
as a I said I will take a look at the
behind the scenes stuff and the
interviews with RTD and decide if I have
another video in me worth of stuff to
talk about that I kind of suspect not
but we'll see um I have seen the uh
reveal of shy goa's Sonic Screwdriver
I'm going to do a short on that probably
out I don't know Tuesday Wednesday I
don't know um but I do have some
thoughts on that just not enough for a
full video so I think uh I think that'll
about wrap it up thanks so much for
tuning in there was obviously a lot to
talk about and I didn't really sum up my
overall opinion uh which if you couldn't
guess I like this it did take me some
time to come to the conclusion that I
like the by
generation and the reason I like it is
because of the storytelling it enables
to happen as an event unto itself I'm
not that thrilled about it and I
definitely don't want to ever see it
happen again but I've seen the immediate
result of what story we get because
because it
happened and I like that a lot so
between how much fun I had in the first
half and how
warm the last third I guess or so of the
episode made
me yeah I like this one a fair bit so
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are I've talked about
plenty of things so whatever your
thoughts on what you saw or what you
heard me ramble out of my mouth are drop
down in the comments let's talk about it
patreon pays the bills and enables me to
do this as my living uh if you can't
help me out that way like share
subscribe those are also a big help
there's links to other things I do down
in the in the description but don't
worry too much about
it what I really want you to
remember is that you are
beautiful you are valid and you are
loved you are the council and I just
running the meetings and until till next
time this council is
[Music]
adjourned time for me to thank my
highest supporting patrons Robin Moore
Zubin Lula goddess ala Oliver be to rock
the thing that goes doink in the anime
Ruth goes with the gazarian solitary
pictures rri bugden geek filter Linda
Walters toku BL huian Jen ay K 808 Becky
Sparks rabi likes the poodle Robin
Powell t love Tracy scrapit and angry
caspel Dave Hall quite bearish Roslin
Bennett pal baraba
jagal I'm sorry for whatever Butchery I
did to that and miror G I know I've kind
of done like funky stuff saying them the
last few times I had this whole idea
where I was going to like sing them to
the tune of Carol the Bells but then I
realized it's going to like Clash with
my outro music and I didn't really want
to rework that or just cut the outro
music out all together that felt weird
so I just just didn't just didn't I just
didn't do a thing this time but now I've
told you that I didn't do a thing so
I've made a thing about there being no
thing okay thanks for sticking around
bye